I have a really quick announcement for you today
I'm starting to New YouTube channels and the links are in the description box below you can check them out and click subscribe
The first Channel is called the Mark Wiens vlog
And I'm going to be posting more uncut more laid-back videos on that channel
Plus some of the content that doesn't make it to the main channel. I'll be posting it all on the Mark wiens vlog
lots more food and travel on that channel and
then the second channel is called Mark Abroad and
We get to travel we travel a lot
And we stay in a lot of different
Accommodation and so I thought it would be cool to give you tours of all the different accommodation that we stay from
from hotels to local apartments and homes we've been staying in a lot of apartments, especially since having a baby and
so I'll be giving you tours of
Accommodation on Mark Abroad and I should also say that nothing will change on my main channel
I'm still going to be posting as regular two videos per week
But I wanted to give you some different angles of videos and provide you with more content
I'm having a really quick lunch at home today. This is called domicile Bacca Bacca and this is a sour
Southern Thai soup
With I think it's mullet fish check out this guy. There's big chunks of turmeric in there. That's why it's so yellow. There's chillies
There's garlic in here and look at all that lemongrass. Oh yeah taste that broth first oh
yeah, it's sour really sour you can taste that like mustardy turmeric in there and then for a
Piece of fish which I will grab off the side of that
Put it on to my rice
Also, one of my personal favorite dishes. I'm glad my mother-in-law made this today
I just I don't know if it's pork or chicken stir-fried with stink beans
And you can just see those are loaded with stink beans
You can even see all the all the finely shaved Kaptur lime leaves in there
And then that is a thick curry paste stir-fried up call. Yes
This is one of the ultimates oh
ma'am
That is just a mouthful of stink beans. It's spicy. You can taste black pepper in there it has a
citrusy taste from all those finely shaved Kaffir lime leaves
and then just an entire spoonful of stink beans that just can't be beat and then just a simple plate of
These are straw mushrooms stir-fried wooden complextro sauce and some green onions in there
Stick this onto my rice
Simple classic, this is just a very normal typical meal that I eat at home in Bangkok. My mother-in-law is an awesome cook ah
The next videos that I'm going to post are cambodia so stay tuned for Cambodia videos we had some
Incredible seafood we went to this place to eat crab on the coast and then we did some some of theirs
Cambodia is just an amazing street food Paradise, and I'll be posting Cambodia videos next also
We have a couple of unique very exciting trips coming up that I know I don't know all the details yet
But I'm going to be excited to share it with you very soon
And you can also follow my instagram for current updates my Instagram account will be in the description Box below
And finally I want to ask you if you have any suggestions of where we should travel to eat
Maybe in the next couple months
We'll try to take some trips, and I would love your recommendations for where to go anywhere in the world
so
That's going to be it for this little short update video remember to check out the two new YouTube channels if you're interested in lots
of more content and
I want to say a big. Thank you to you for all of your support
Throughout and for watching all of our videos. Hope you have a fantastic lunch and
I'll see you on the next video